that was obviously the phenomenal greg
kinnear in his horror comedy show almost
hard to pin it down phenomenal tone
called shining veil yes tell us about
the show it's on stars uh we just
debuted on the 6th march and it's it's
comedy and it's horror and there's a
mystery in it and it's this family in
new york
who are you know they've had this you
know thing my wife america sweetheart
courtney cox has said yeah we love her
so much she's had an indiscretion
and um
imagine and we move out to
the country i find a house 200 000 below
asking deep in connecticut
and i wonder why i think you know hey
here's a deal but it's just like we're
in this
freaky house and it's um i i don't
really see a lot of what's happening
she's seeing things that i'm not seeing
so i don't get to do a lot of the
you know horror looks but i love the
tone of this show because it's it is
creepy and scary and then there's like
levity
i don't think so i don't either
i believe in everything but a lot of
people have are you amazed at how many
people have an experience of having seen
something or believe they've seen
something you know otherworldly it sort
of makes sense it's like you know ufos
and aliens like come on of course there
are other life there's other life you
know and that's not just the e.t in me
talking right right you would think that
that was
i mean
that's just
you're the only one who can say that's
not just the e-t in me talking no one
else can say that listen tots i'm not
talking
as a citizen of the world there's no way
we're alone
it's not possible
so i'm open to everything you had me at
toots right i like to kick an old school
speaking of old school someone else that
we worked with in common is gary
marshall um he's a lovely man he really
loves man gary marshall is so excited
did you talk to you
yeah i'm sure he did i'm sure he did is
it true that he had a weird food combo
that he really liked he would always be
on set and he'd say uh get me my bananas
and tuna fish
and
for real and he would he would get
bananas and tuna fish is his thing and
it uh it stayed with me my whole life i
have a feeling that something bad angel
thank you
oh look how like lovely they made these
thank you angel
um
have you ever tried the banana
the nana tuna i have not ever done this
nana tuna should we try it in honor of
gary
i know i'm a little nervous
i mean really i feel like i'm on fear
factor
hey
i feel a new segment coming on
all right
gary i hope you're watching
not as bad as i thought
i do think just
just a tiny bit of like a sour cream and
a chive would also really up the game i
think this could be perfected i do too
okay
[Music]